why are we putting up this exactly and
who's running it
well kamala harris or kamala harris
depending on the day is officially in
charge of it she's our border czar
that's what joe biden says but she
doesn't seem very interested in the job
instead she spent the last week filming
a truly bizarre video for world space
week but don't take our word for it
here it is
i just love the idea of exploring the
unknown
and then there's other things that we
just haven't figured out or discovered
yet to think about so much that's out
there that we still have to learn
like i love that i love that and so i'm
very excited about the space council
we're going to learn so much
um as we increasingly i think are
curious
and interested in the potential for
the discoveries and the work we can do
in space so
that's one of the things i'm most
excited about
but the other
you guys are gonna see you're gonna
literally see the craters on the moon
with your own eyes
with your own eyes i'm telling you it is
gonna be
unbelievable
[Music]
so for humanitarian reasons we're not
going to play that whole video but it's
online if you dare look it up watch it
watch it again watch your own soul die
as you do
it's the fakest thing that's ever been
caught on video but in fact it's even
faker than it looks we've just learned
that one of the kids that kamala harris
was lecturing at is in fact not a normal
kid he's a child actor called trevor who
auditioned for that role
no political party that believed in
democracy and thought it had to win over
voters would ever put up someone like
camel or kamala harris for office so
what does this tell us about the
democratic party candace owens is the
host of candace she joins us tonight
kenneth owens thanks so much for coming
on so i don't know if you dared to watch
that whole thing and i'm not just being
mean for political reasons
i've never seen anything that fraudulent
in my whole life
it is really a bizarre thing to watch
and it's just the thing that's bizarre
it's like you question yourself has she
ever even been around children by the
way right these are as you reported this
is somebody who was a child actor who
reached out to his agent and asked to
get this part he was called back weeks
later and said yes you got the part to
star along the vice president united
states and try to normalize and humanize
her which he you know unfortunately for
him he failed that because it's hard to
humanize uh kamala harris and what's
more bizarre is that he's 13 years old
why is she speaking to 13 year olds like
this she's speaking like they're five
years old using the expressions and
using her hands as if you're reading the
hungry hungry caterpillar to a
kindergarten class it's so scripted
there's nothing authentic about her at
all and then you wonder what like to me
personally whenever i watch her i wonder
whether or not forget whether or not she
wants to be in front of children does
she even want to be the vice president i
think that's a question that's not a lot
a lot of americans minds when it comes
to her because every time you see her
she just seems so phony it seems like
she's playing a part that she genuinely
doesn't want to play i think that people
that are accurately reporting that there
seems to be the shade war going on
between kamala harris and joe biden i
think that's accurate i think she
genuinely resents being the vice
president united states she genuinely
resents being subordinate to biden and
she genuinely resents every element of
her job including scripted elements like
the one that we had to watch just
tonight yeah because i mean it's a
different level they're all phony all
politicians are phony every single one
of them all weird creepy personal lives
got it
but she's so phony that her phoniness is
an act of aggression aimed at her
audience i mean she's daring you to
watch her without vomiting i mean she's
literally that phony
yeah she's so unlikable it's harder it's
hard to think that they could ever put
forth a woman that was more likable than
hillary clinton but by golly a democrat
party is yeah i find her to be more
unbearable and more unlikable than
hillary clinton somehow and it's because
it's the acting behind it's the phony
laugh it's the cackling laugh you know
and again to have to go out and get
actors we see joe biden appearing in
front of us set at the eeob we've got
kamala harris hiring child actors i mean
what is actually going on in this
administration this really does feel
like it's a saturday night live skits
you know the same amount of viewers not
not very many but it's like do we have
people that are actually running our
country or do we have actors that are
just sitting around you know saying what
they're supposed to say reading off of
teleprompters why don't they just let us
read the teleprompter it'd be much
easier
i totally agree she leaves you pining
for the authentic maternal warmth of
hillary clinton i mean it's that bad
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else